It doesn't disturb me at all.
I'm,
I'm always
believe in talking to my opponents and
stayed friends.
I mean,
you know it just so the people I
disagree with most strongly,
I'm actually quite friendly with this.
Nope.
It doesn't make.
It doesn't disturb me if they disagree
with me.
Well,
I don't know.
It changes from week to week.
What I've noticed is there's been a
strong increase in skepticism and just
in the last couple of weeks,
and
I suppose it has something to do with
all this snow storms we've been having.
I don't know,
but certainly I've seen the politicians
becoming much more skeptical just
recently.
That's across.
I welcome that.
I think that that that's
actually means they're recognizing the
way things are.
Well,
there are all sorts of ways.
It was a couple of farmers in Minnesota
I was just reading about who decided to
change from feed lots to grass.
Was there raising beef that there.
These are farmers who are just raising
cows for beef,
add a certain amount of milk as well,
and they decided to switch from feed
lots,
which is of course the fashionable way
of raising cows.
You keep them on a very crowded feed lot
and feed them on call,
so you're growing corn to feed to the
animals.
Instead of that,
you put them out to grass,
but you manage the grass in a clever way
with moving fences around.
So they actually eat the grass much more
evenly.
It turns out this pace and,
and uh,
it's uh,
they're doing extremely well just going
back from feed lots to grass and it has
a big effect on the carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere in proportion to the area
that they're using.
That means that if the whole of the
Middle West would do this,
it would make a very substantial
difference to the carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere.
And so that kind of,
that's the sort of practical thing you
can do just managing the land more
intelligently.
And this,
it's rather like building dikes around
new orleans.
I mean,
it's,
it's not all that spectacular,
but it actually works and
so changing from feed lots to grass,
I think it's sort of,
it doesn't solve the whole problem,
but it solves a certain chunk of the
problem and there are other things you
can do.
Just doing less plowing makes a huge
difference.
Plowing is one of the main causes of
carbon going into the atmosphere because
you expose the soil to the atmosphere at
means.
The carbon gets oxidized,
becomes carbon dioxide and floats off
into the atmosphere.
So if you can find without plowing,
it actually helps and doesn't matter how
much coal and oil burning that still
helps.